sur ces images satellites un convoi
russe s'étire sur 60 km
des véhicules blindés de l'artillerie
des camions de ravitaillement direction
la capitale ukrainienne
contre les Kiev et l'objectif principal
du Kremlin cette nuit les troupes russes
ont à nouveau bombardés la ville
obligeant la population à ce cloîtrer
sous terre
interrogé par France 24 cet habitante
témoignent
cette nuit on passe le temps dans le
couloir de notre appartement parce que
c'est c'est le place le plus sécurisé de
notre appartement
aussi la deuxième ville du crâne les
bombardements s'intensifient les
quartiers résidentiels sont touchés
selon les autorités locales il y aurait
plusieurs morts parmi les civils
car qui reste pour le moment sous
contrôle ukrainien mais à Carson dans le
sud-ouest du pays les Russes sont déjà
aux portes de la ville selon le maire
l'armée aurait installé des postes de
contrôle à tous les points d'entrée
enfin à octet
les autorités locales ont annoncé ce
mardi la mort de plus de 70 soldats
Ukrainiens victimes du bombardement de
leur base militaire qui remontent à
dimanche